open up your wallet you'd expect to find
ones tens 20s maybe even a hundo the
last thing you'd ever expect is a Tom
also known as a $2 bill here's why it
was 1862 the federal government had just
started printing its first paper money
the first and only denominations were
the $1 and $2 bills and keep in mind at
the time people were making about $15 a
month to pay using a $2 bill was a
status symbol only the wealthiest of
Americans could afford and a lot of the
time they used them for under-the-table
transactions like political bribes
prostitutes and gambling the Tom
ultimately got a bad rap and was deemed
unnecessary in 1966 the government took
a 10-year hiatus and stopped printing
those bad boys but in 1976 the
government gave them another try
this time classing them up a bit issuing
a special Bicentennial bill a little too
classy some would argue people began
hiding them away as collectors items
leading to less bills in circulation
which brings us to present day though
rare Tom's are still being printed and
there are over a billion in circulation
most people keep them as keepsakes
though there is a subculture of $2
ambassadors who are set on keeping the
Tom alive by using them every chance
they get so the next time you're paying
with cash
go ahead use a Tom
you